Travis got kicked me off the stage and
this is that story so this all starts in
the summer 2015 at the time I'm working
at hot 97 as a video producer go Google
hot 97 right now one of New York's
biggest radio stations for hip-hop and
R&B I'm working summer jam summer jam is
one of the biggest concert series as far
as hip hop and R&B you can have it is
legendary
when I say legendary I mean these type
of people
part of me is super excited so if you
grew up in New York City you know
exactly what summer jam is the feeling
especially it'd be big but now I have to
work the concert and who wants to work
that long air show not this guy Mythili
I had to prep the whole team gets there
at 9:00 a.m. and it's hot not like
regular but like hot so the whole team
had specific assignments some people
were gonna check the co-direct some
people were gonna be in the pit
videotaping the artists some people are
gonna be backstage doing interviews with
all the artists I me on the other hand
was a sign to follow one of the
station's personalities around for six
hours following around a person talking
to famous people is like watching
somebody play a bomb-ass video game but
like you're not playing Jesus watching
so that was my assignment I had to
follow around
Ebro Darden it was an amazing radio
personality at hot 97 but I didn't want
to follow him around and clearly he
didn't want me to either because he
pushed our assignment from one o'clock
to four o'clock so I asked my boys like
what am I supposed to do here he was
like hey take initiative I don't know
what that means okay
had I known better how to probably just
fell asleep in a porta potti somewhere
but I didn't I took initiative I said
you know what I'm gonna go out and i'ma
go tape some before you actually go into
MetLife Stadium there's a festival stage
which is outside these performers who
are about to blow up perform
I had my wristlets which let me get into
everywhere so I went on stage I was in
back and people like Teyana Taylor were
performing but 49 and Taylor was like
huge I'm filming and I
learn how to put like cameras in slow
motion like a week before so I was like
to tomorrow it was like beep beep you
know I was feeling very good weight
today see the initiative
I took I'm even under walkie talkie like
hey I just won today I'm feeling really
good you know I can't get in contact
with Ebro cuz he's off doing famous
people stuff what could go wrong you ask
well I come back to the stage there's
one more act left this guy named Travis
guy young emerging artists from Houston
so I hadn't heard a lot about Travis at
that time I mean he was buzzing he was
definitely buzzing and you could tell by
the energy and on the stage just jumping
around going what a rage let's everybody
rain security raging right now and I'm
like wait a minute
let's rage within reason since as soon
as this dais goes down I'm suing
everybody and it's jamia light Stadium
half today so as this whole rage is
happening I'm in the back I'm capturing
all kind of shots
it's looking good I was on stage so long
cuz guitar player
pass me a blunt I stay drug-free so I
said no thank you sir but I felt like
family honestly at this point in time
this is the highlight of my day I mean
I'm not like really working so then out
of nowhere music cuts off
Travis turns around and goes yo bro just
a nerdy ass off the stage in my mind I'm
like wow whoever's behind me it was
really gonna have a problem on their
hands because he wouldn't treat family
like that they passed me a blight but as
he started coming closer and pointing
I'm like oh he might be talking to me
and while we were face to face I knew he
was talking to me I tried to you know be
cool because you know I acquired 401k I
quiet some dental don't wanna mess up
anything that's fine I'm fine so I said
hey mr. sky I actually work here so I'm
good if you doing your job look it up my
stage few variables came up in my mind
one I'm from Brooklyn Brooklyn New York
you go punch this dude in the throat
second thing I'm thinking
I'm sure tiny bit of a Napoleon complex
and I gotta look up at him third thing
I'm thinking about let him beat you
first so that you could sue so as I'm
thinking about all these things somebody
from his crew is pulling me but at that
point I didn't care so I asked him I was
like so you want to fight no problem an
artist I just have a reputation you
gotta get on my stage and I was like
okay I don't care and then I saw a
security card
I can't a little bit I cared a lot of it
and then I finally got off and left
because I said all right he should not
be back in the reality I'm pissed off
there's a whole bunch of people around
me I took a minute I was sad I said whoo
whoo shabu-shabu so chill and my phone
started blowing I forgot to take an
account that this was the first year
that Summer Jam was live streaming so
what I thought was embarrassing for me
in front of thousands of people quickly
it was a realization that millions of
people had watch this my girlfriend said
oh my god
we heard that you got thrown off the
stage how you did and Twitter was on
fire I saw a clip that went viral and I
quoted it and I said hey that's me lol
I'm fine
people started adding me throughout the
day I was like why you mad at me cuz I
got thrown off the zoo well you
shouldn't have been there in the first
place
you were I'm like you don't even know me
but dear me your location we could
settle this right now
so I had to deal with that the whole day
and no closure that's crazy right that's
not even the apex of the story I haven't
even told you the best part
aren't so days after that I did an
interview with complex he I did an
interview talking about it at this at
our sister station at the time which is
power 106 just talking about like how he
felt I spoke about how I felt I didn't
really care but at that time I felt like
it was closure in a sense because
physically we hadn't seen each other so
I was put it's a bad whole summer goes
by stand there in the end of August and
my coworker one night
before we had a shoot said I think
Travis Scott put you in his new song
what does that mean
playing a song I mean I'm not like
really impressive well it's cool
this is fine Travis so there's a line
that stands out towards the end of the
song and it says kicking the cameraman
off on my face because I don't like I
step in my
a fiery rage comes back over me like oh
you really think I'm a those few months
that happened afterwards I couldn't
escape it every time I was at my job I
heard I woke up to pee 3 o'clock in the
morning you know you fall asleep when
George Lopez is playing on MTV got back
in my bag and the video visual at that
point in time I felt like he just
targeted me one on one
I couldn't stand Travis guy but that
damn song that's a good a song now
weirdly after day I liked his music I
don't know I sure feel about that and
every now and again on Twitter I have to
raise my hand and be like hey that's me
so what's the message that you leave
with for watching this video
initiative sometimes could put you in a
multi-platinum recording artist song